people learn in different ways have an
audio version have a hardback have the
digital reader version have the video
version each of these are different ways
that people going to consume on my last
book 100 m offers which now is I think
350,000 copies sold so I have a decent
data set it's almost a perfect quarter
quarter quarter quarter split in terms
of where people consume it if I had only
released an e version of this 3/4 of the
people who have ultimately bought Andor
consumed that lead magnet would never
have done it and so little effort to
just double and triple and quadruple how
many more people consume it simply by
making it available in more ways to more
people in more places